LORRAINE CINK: Marvel
Studios' Moon Knight
has some otherworldly
action, which
is why I'm breaking it down
with VFX Supervisor Sean Faden.
Hey, Sean.
Hey Lorraine.
Now let's kick
off with episode two
where we see Mr.
Knight facing off
against that invisible jackal.
How did you and your team first
start to approach that scene?
There was a lot of
weight on this scene,
and making sure
that it landed well.
It actually starts
in the alleyways.
You've got Mr. Knight being sort
of blown through this fence.
We spent a lot of time
pre-vising this scene
because it was-- he had
the complications of having
to have an invisible opponent.
The jackal is only
visible occasionally
during the sequence.
We had a lot of
storyboards that we
got from one of our main
storyboard artists, Phil
Langone.
It wasn't for every
single sequence,
but when we did get them,
they were extremely helpful.
In the end, how
we shot it was we
had a stunt person
in a gray suit
pushing and pulling
our stunt Moon Knight,
or Oscar and Layla around.
For me, the most important
thing to capture for real
was leaping, or
landing, or running.
We did shoot, when
possible, references.
I think that if you end
up doing too much CG
throughout every
single shot, you end
up losing some of the reality.
So we always tried to
shoot with real stunts.
While we're
talking battles, we
have to talk about
the end of the series
where we see your techniques
taken to new heights
quite literally with a huge
god versus god battle in Cairo.
How did you go about
approaching that scene
and bringing it to life?
SEAN FADEN: It was a
combination of a lot of pre-vis,
some storyboarding, a
lot of back and forth
with our stunt team, trying
to figure out what the best
flow of fight choreography was
going to be for these moments,
and making sure that we were
seeing Khonshu getting to be
heroic and seeing Ammit use some
of her crocodile related fight
moves.
We actually did a lot of work
within the Chamber of the Gods,
because we have a scene
that takes place there
where Khonshu and Ammit are
normal size, which means
they're actually 9 feet tall.
We had pre-vised all
this stuff, and then
we went and we shot a
lot of background plates
within our set, which sometimes
are just looking at a column,
and the rest would
be blue screen.
They created costumes
for Ammit and Khonshu.
Real costumes that moved
like the real thing, that
look like the real
thing, that could be
lit like the real thing.
So it wasn't just guys in
gray suits running around.
We actually had a lightable
Khonshu and Ammit in our scene,
and they were able to
act against each other.
The scale of the two characters
mainly became an issue
when we were dealing
with other actors that
needed to interact with them.
So if Oscar was talking to
Khonshu, than Karim, who played
Khonshu on set, would be
wearing an eyeline pole
to make him look 9 feet tall.
It was literally
two ping pong balls
on the end of a composite rod
that was attached to his--
like a lightweight vest that
our props department made.
The gods are
already quite tall,
but then they grow even larger.
How did you create this
scene at such an epic scale?
So they're almost as
tall as the pyramids,
and they're bashing
around and wreaking havoc.
Weta created a full CG Giza
plateau based on some lidar
that we had gotten
from Disney archives.
We had a lot of work that went
into figuring out just how
much dust or how much
light should be hitting
these characters to
make them feel big,
and what we found was the less
light we put on them, the more
that we sort of played the
light falling off on them,
the bigger they felt.
This is really just a tiny
drop in the bucket of all
of the action in this series.
Looking back, are there
any moments that you
think fans might have missed?
The series is jam packed
with lots of cool details.
I don't think you're going to
catch it on the first viewing.
I really think it's one of
those things you have to watch
a few times to really
appreciate all the detail
and heart that went
into these moments.
All right, well I guess
I'm going to have to go
start my rewatch right now.
So Sean, thank you so
much for talking with us.
Well, I appreciate it.
Thanks Lorraine.
And everyone, be
sure to go watch
Marvel Studios' Moon Knight.
All episodes are now
streaming, only on Disney+.